[Music]
[Music]
this is euglena Aaron argi
and as you can see it's a bit of a
shapeshifter
it's not just changing its shape though
it's moving across the surface of this
unicellular eukaryotes a series of
strips made out of protein run the
length of the cell working with a system
of molecular tubes to drive this
cellular contortionist around in a form
of movement known as metabolites those
strips create a ridged surface along the
plasma membrane called the pellicle and
this is the structure that unites the
otherwise incredibly diverse set of
organisms called you glenoid you glenoid
are mostly found in freshwater where
many species get their food by engulfing
it through a process known as
phagocytosis millions are maybe even a
billion years ago the thing that got
engulfed was a photosynthetic green
algae and this marks a major division
any ugly noise like this para NEMA don't
have chloroplasts instead these
non-photosynthetic species rely on
feeding mechanisms like phagocytosis or
osmosis but the ugly noids were going to
talk about today are the ones whose
ancestors not only ingested the green
algae they took on the algie's
chloroplasts and the rest of the
photosynthetic apparatus evolving the
ability to make their own food
in addition to consuming nutrients from
their environment as we mentioned
earlier the common link between new
glenoid is that striped surface called
the pellicle other than that though you
glenoid x' can look pretty different
from each other the most common shape
among new glenoid is this sort of
elongated almond shape where the end
comes to a tapered point then there are
these mato more fina
Pyron whose bodies are more rounded and
have a clearer tail coming out at one
end you can see mono morphine opium here
as well along with fakest tortoise
almost all fakest species have this sort
of flat Dimond body resembling a leaf
and some like this thickest heel
acquittees can twist that leaf into an
amazing and beautiful corkscrew like
structure fakest species do have a
pellicle but they're rigid and can't
actually engage in metabolites that
shape-shifting method of locomotion we
saw in the beginning that is so common
to you glenoid that it's also called you
glenoid movement in general the
flexibility of you glenoid corresponds
to the number of protein strips and it's
pelicans species that are less rigid and
thus more likely to use metabolites have
more strips while more rigid species
have fewer strips so you might be
wondering how these rigid species get
around if they can't rely on wiggling
their bodies to different places the
answer is simple flagella all
photosynthetic you glenoid x' have two
or more of those hair like structures
that they use to move even if they are
capable of mentality
the flagella are a little hard to see if
you squint you might see them here
towards the front end of the cell which
is also where you'll find that distinct
reddish spot that looks kind of like an
eye that red spot is appropriately
enough the eye spot though it doesn't
actually see instead the eye spot works
as a sort of shading device that along
with photoreceptive proteins at the base
of the flagella tells the cell where it
can find light to drive photosynthesis
now despite their ancient green algae
origins the chloroplasts and
photosynthetic you clean nodes are a bit
different from their ancestral
counterparts particularly in how they
store their energy green algae make a
starch that is stored in the
chloroplasts for their later energetic
needs because the Sun never shines all
day but you glenoid x' produce a
different carbohydrate stock called para
myelin that's kept in the cytoplasm of
the cell
instead of in the chloroplast
different.you glenoid x' keep their para
myelin stored in different shapes
ranging from small discs to larger rods
as this you glenoid turns you can
actually see its para Milam bodies it's
those oval ring structures and when the
cell uses the para Milon for energy
those rings will become thinner
of course as we've seen in other
episodes things in the micro cosmos can
get tough so some new glenoid z' build
their own defenses this is struggle
notice and I should say here that I am
fumbling through some of these
pronunciations so don't take them as
gospel it's encased in a protective
structure called the lorica a sugary
matrix that the cell produces when it's
young the lorica starts out as a softer
more flexible covering but over time it
picks up minerals like iron and becomes
increasingly solid you can tell that
compared to the other very green new
Glee noids we've shown this little guy
is more on the yellowish side and that
color actually comes from those embedded
minerals these Euglena sanguine ax are
demonstrating another use for sticky
encasements under stress these cells
have entered what's called the palmela
stage on the right side of this clip you
can see four cells enclosed in a clear
membrane and when this little click was
started it was originally just one cell
that had lost its flagella and enclosed
itself in a capsule of its own making in
time that one cell divided into two and
then those two cells divided into four
when conditions are right these cells
can leave the capsule and reform their
flagella you glenoid have had a very
very long time to evolve and as we have
seen the things that they have evolved
into our diverse so diverse that
combined with the varied shape-shifting
abilities of its member species you
glenoid x' have proven challenging both
to identify and to classify
in the past few centuries attempts to
categorize them have resulted in their
inclusion with animals with plants and
with protists as well as declarations of
their own kingdom the microscope is a
powerful tool but this is where
molecular tools like gene sequencing
take over helping scientists better
understand just how the species of this
vast group are related to each other and
to everything else and even as these
threads of evolution get untangled and
old questions get answered there will
only be more questions to ask and more
opportunities to wonder thank you for
coming on this journey with us as we
explore the unseen world that surrounds
us if you want to see more from our
master of microscopes James Weiss check
out Jam and germs on Instagram and if
you want to come back to see more of the
beautiful weird world of the micro there
is probably a subscribe button that you
can click on
[Music]
you